[Música]
la historia de Beatriz es la siguiente
tenía 22 años un hijo pequeño y lupus
todo esto en un contexto de
vulnerabilidad económica en una sala de
urgencias se enteró de que estaba
nuevamente embarazada y al menos 15
doctores le recomendaron un aborto
terapéutico porque uno el embarazo ponía
en riesgo su vida dada su condición y
dos el feto era inviable al carecer de
cerebro y de cráneo a pesar de esto El
Salvador le negó el aborto terapéutico y
tiempo después falleció dejando un hijo
huérfano y es que la interrupción del
embarazo es ilegal en todos los casos en
ese país este jueves continúa una
audiencia histórica por este caso en la
corte idh y ya se entregaron los
primeros argumentos en la defensa del
Estado vamos a conversar sobre este
conflicto con Cristina Rosero quien es
abogada senior del centro de derechos
reproductivos una de las organizaciones
además litigantes en este caso
bienvenida Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo América qué tal
Buenos días y muchas gracias por la
invitación pues vamos a comenzar sin
demora porque hay mucho que decir sobre
este caso de Beatriz versus El Salvador
que se dijo en el primer día de
audiencias bueno en el primer día de
audiencias empezaron a retomarse algunas
peritajes y algunos testimonios de
personas relevantes dentro del caso y lo
que nos deja concluir Este primer día es
que en efecto hubo una serie de
violaciones a derechos humanos muy
graves derivadas de las acciones del
Salvador frente a Beatriz está muy claro
ya que el embarazo era totalmente
inviable y que a pesar de que no había
una vida prenatal que proteger mediante
una prohibición del aborto en este caso
lo que en lo que se incurrió fue en una
demora totalmente injustificada de la
realización de un procedimiento que ella
necesitaba para preservar su vida y por
esa razón como un resultado pues ella
sufrió una serie de consecuencias muy
graves a su salud y por supuesto después
eso tuvo un impacto en una muerte muy
prematura por su parte Claro que
inicialmente diríamos no estaba
relacionada directamente con el parto
pero que Y tuvo que ver mucho con su
condición de salud y esto lo traigo a
colación porque la interrupción del
embarazo Debería ser aunque sea
moralmente cuestionada o no la decisión
de la mujer involucrada no esto no
sucede y mucho menos en El Salvador pero
incluso hay casos en que la urgencia de
verlo como un derecho humano Es evidente
y Beatriz es un ejemplo de ello porque
su vida estaba en peligro sí sin duda
Este es un caso totalmente extremo es
decir en este punto era un embarazo
totalmente inviable las consecuencias
para ella eran demasiado difíciles y que
ni siquiera en un caso extremo como este
El Salvador haya flexibilizado la
interpretación de esta prohibición del
aborto nos muestra las gravísimas
consecuencias que ese tipo de
regulaciones limitantes pueden crear
para la vida y la salud de las mujeres
este caso sin duda es emblemático porque
nos muestra Hacia dónde puede llegar una
prohibición del aborto y sin duda la
decisión que se tome como resultado de
este caso va a ser una influencia muy
importante para la región entera porque
recordemos que los de la Corte
Interamericana No solo le aplican al
país que está siendo procesado dentro
del juicio sino que son un precedente
relevante para la región completa y eso
podría tener que ver con República
Dominicana Nicaragua Haití y Honduras
que son los otros cuatro países que
prohíben en su totalidad de pues eh los
efectos del aborto ahora sin embargo
nayib bukele salió sin pena a decir que
no habría un cambio en la legislación
respecto al derecho a la vida que está
consagrado en la constitución
en un eventual fallo cuánto tardaría Y
qué efecto Podría tener para obligar al
gobierno a realizar cambios es difícil
predecir Cuál será la actitud del
gobierno porque de paso Tenemos también
que saber en qué términos se da el fallo
en el presente en la presente sentencia
Pero lo que sí es verdad es que el
Salvador Al haber suscrito la convención
americana sobre Derechos Humanos tiene
unas obligaciones claras de acogerse a
los fallos establecidos por la Corte
Interamericana es decir la obligación
del estado está allí reconocida y estos
fallos son vinculantes por lo tanto
cualquier tipo de demora en adoptar las
directrices que la corte establezcan
esta sentencia sin duda se configuraría
en una en un incumplimiento de las
obligaciones internacionales a las que
El Salvador Se comprometió Al momento de
firmar la convención y acatarla dentro
de sus normas bien Cristina quiero
pedirle que andemos un poco más en los
argumentos o para que el Salvador asuma
la responsabilidad por las violaciones a
los derechos humanos de Beatriz y de
tantas otras mujeres porque Bueno Este
es un caso específico pero el estado
tiene la obligación de proteger a sus
ciudadanas sí sin duda para nosotros un
punto muy importante Resaltar Es que la
prohibición total del aborto como está
establecida en El Salvador viola los
derechos fundamentales de las mujeres y
las niñas este caso va a complementar lo
que ya la corte pudo ver en el caso de
Manuela contra El Salvador que lo llevó
la corte también la el centro de derecho
reproductivos porque en este caso se
mostró como incluso una mujer que no
buscaba voluntario sino que sufrió una
pérdida del embarazo involuntaria fue
procesada 30 años como resultado de que
sus médicos asumieron que ella buscó un
aborto involuntario entonces la corte
tiene la oportunidad de avanzar aún más
lo que ya empezó con el caso de Manuela
y Mostrar cómo esta es una violación muy
grave de los derechos fundamentales de
las mujeres y por lo tanto las
legislaciones limitativas del aborto
deberían ser cambiadas Ya se nos va
acabando el tiempo pero para una última
intervención a las mujeres en El
Salvador en las cárceles las llaman las
mata niños y las siguen criminalizando
también en las calles por los abortos
sean o no sean voluntarios Y esto es un
gravísimo problema quisiera su
conclusión sobre criminalizar a las
mujeres por tener dominio sobre su
cuerpo sí la existencia sola del delito
ya es una base para crear una serie de
estigmas y de prejuicios en contra de
las mujeres que toman una decisión sobre
su salud reproductiva y sobre su vida y
esto es muy grave porque lleva a que no
solamente las mujeres que hayan buscado
un aborto voluntario sean proces sino
también por ejemplo mujeres que
sufrieron una emergencia por lo tanto
está muy claro que el delito de aborto
no sirve para eliminar o disminuir la
cantidad de abortos que ocurren sino lo
único que hace es tener unas graves
consecuencias sobre la vida y la salud
de las mujeres que en este momento
deberían empezar a cambiar y como
siempre así como lo muestra el caso de
Beatriz las más afectadas son las
mujeres en mayores condiciones de
vulnerabilidad hoy tenemos a un niño que
se quedó sin mamá una madre que se quedó
sin hija un hermano que se quedó sin
hermana y la lista podría seguir
Cristina gracias Un placer hablar con
usted y pues estaremos esperando los
resultados de este caso de la idh
Muchísimas gracias por invitarme a
nuestros televidentes continúen con
nosotros en directo América minutos y ya
regresamos con más
[Música]